Well, good morning church.
Uh, it's good to be back together.
I missed being with you last week,
but I wanna say a big thank you to Alan
for handling the words so well.
Uh, talking about being peacemakers within the church
as well as outside the church.
It was powerful to listen to that this week.
But as we get into today's segment of
what a realigned life in Christ looks like,
I just wanna be upfront and tell you that out
of the entire series, I feel the most
unqualified to preach this topic.
I mean, every week we've seen right,
how far from Christ's standard we actually are, right?
We, we see it every week that we're far from
what Jesus modeled for us.
But today's topic of humility
and its antithesis, pride has been one of my life's biggest
struggles going all the way back.
You think of my teen years just characterized by,
by blatant selfishness.
And I really loved the, uh, the notoriety
that would come with being good at sports or academics
or even public speaking, even to my early,
early ministry where it was characterized by
so much self-sufficiency, like,
I can make this church thing work
with my talent, my resources.
Yeah, let's do it.
It shows up over the years through sermon illustrations
where I make myself the hero.
Rather than letting you see like the real
and raw who John Wolgemuth actually is, kind of thing.
Put up a facade. Lets you only see part.
It looks good on the outside.
Listen, those are all forms of pride,
which means I need this sermon more than you do.
But I would also imagine that like,
like I'm not alone in those things.
I would imagine that you probably felt a little bit
of maybe some of those things I was
talking about in your life.
I also know there's things like false humility
that may be where you're at, where you cut yourself down
to draw attention or
you love to flaunt the way your body looks to others.
Or even just a base level lack
of dependence on God at all.
That's all pride. That's why like
this is so critical today that we need to get this.
Because way back in, uh, the early three hundreds,
Augustine said, pride is the beginning of sin.
Like all sin, pride is the start of it.
Pride is the initiator of it.
It's, it's that the, it is an a sin in itself,
but it's also the root of all others.
Like if we're arrogant or,
or we think that we're somehow above God's law, then man,
that's gonna get us in trouble really fast.
I deserve this, right?
I should have no, like that's where we go if we have pride.
It's how adultery begins. It's how stealing begins.
It's how lying begins. All of it comes from this pride.
I get to do this, I want to do this.
It's pride that then leads us down the road.
And pride is what gets us further down the road than we
ever thought we would be.
That's why we all need this today desperately.
I don't wanna train wreck my life.
I don't wanna train wreck my ministry.
And I don't want you to bring destruction into your
family, into your life.
I want you to flourish.
It doesn't happen through pride.
And so we're gonna see today how poisonous pride really is.
But thankfully, we'll also see the antidote
and how Jesus himself modeled humility for us.
So we need to pray to get started.
Before we dig into Romans 12, we need to ask God for help.
So Lord, we pray today
and in light of what you want to do
through your word, Lord, it, it is hard words.
But Lord, we know that you have,
you have written this for us.
You've given us your word, you've given us your spirit.
Now, your presence among us. And so Lord, speak, use it.
Change us. Don't let any of us walk away from this moment
the same way we walked in here.
Make us humble. Lord, this is so deeply rooted in all of us.
We've got to have the dynamite of the Holy Spirit
and your word to blow this thing outta here
or it's not going to leave.
Change our hearts.
God, make us more like you
in Jesus authority over all things we pray.
Amen. So here's where we're gonna go today.
We're gonna finish Romans 12, verse 16.
It's there on your notes. If you have the app
where you have the paper copy, it's on the screens as we go
through it, it'll be there.
But, but just a couple simple phrases.
Romans 1216 to finish that verse, here's what it says.
Do not be haughty but associate with the lowly.
Never be wise in your own sight.
Do not be haughty or prideful,
but associate with the lowly.
Never be wise in your own sight.
So again, remember Romans 12 is the Apostle Paul applying
the gospel to those Christians, right?
He's just showing them what a life transformed
by Christ looks like day to day.
This is Romans 12. This is Jesus perfectly living it out.
Here's what we need to be more aligned with as we go.
Well here he's emphasizing a believer's humility.
And he says it in such a way that it's not an option for us
to choose or reject.
This is not an add-on to a, a super spiritual life.
Like, oh man, those are the humble people.
Those are the super Christians.
This is a command for all of us.
Clear from the first phrase, right?
Do not be haughty. Do not be prideful. Do not be arrogant.
Just blatantly clear.
It's not the first time we've seen this though in Romans 12.
It's just a basically a recap of
what we saw back in verse three a few weeks ago.
We saw this for by the grace given to me, I say to everyone
among you not to think of himself more highly
than he ought to think.
That's the same concept here in verse 16, right?
That your frame of mind can be so focused on yourself
that you think you are better than everyone else,
or you think you are awesome compared to everyone else.
Like, I can get there, you can get there.
It's possible that we can think more highly about
ourselves than we ought to.
We can be prideful.
It's the arrogance that Paul warned the Philippian church
about Philippians two verses three and four.
Do nothing from selfish ambition or conceit,
but in humility, count others more
significant than yourselves.
Let each of you look not only to his own interests,
but also to the interests of others.
That's super interesting there
because what he did is he linked selfishness
with pride, with conceit.
And so if you're looking for a test,
this is just simple like, okay,
how do I know if I'm prideful?
Here's a simple test. Are you selfish right now?
Are you being selfish in that moment? That's a test.
He says, do nothing from selfish ambition
or conceit meaning you're looking out for you.
You're looking out for yourself.
If you're ever selfish, that's pride.
Because the posture of your heart in that moment is like,
man, you're here to serve me.
Everything's here about me. I am here to get what I want.
Right? That is pride,
which is a posture then that leads you
to all those other sins as a result.
I want this, I want this, I want this.
So I'm gonna do this to you. I'm gonna ask you to do this.
I'm going to demand this. I'm going to say this.
So you think better about me.
It's all selfishness, it's pride.
That's why Augustine said it's the beginning of sin.
That's why our response must be
to reject the soul destroying poison of pride
like this will destroy our souls if we let it
go, reject it.
It's a poison. It's in us from birth.
Our selfish nature is bent towards this.
It's a poison that is in there from birth.
We must reject it.
'cause here's the reality, Unchecked arrogance
will shipwreck your faith.
Unchecked arrogance will shipwreck your faith.
Now, I'm not saying you can lose your salvation
Because What God has started, God will finish.
If God has saved you, he will save you.
He promises that he will bring that about.
What I'm saying is that pride is what leads you
to refuse to repent when confronted over sin in your life.
And that refusal reveals
Something.
Here's the truth, clearly exposed.
It's in Matthew chapter 18.
It it's typically known as the church discipline passage.
But what you're gonna see here is what,
what I've just talked about, what the word talks about.
You'll see it in action.
Matthew 18, verses 15 through 17.
Listen to what Jesus says is Jesus teaching.
He says, if your brother sins against you, go
and tell him his fault between you and him alone.
If he listens to you, you have gained your brother.
But if he does not listen, take one
or two others along with you
that every charge may be established by the evidence
of two or three witnesses.
If he refuses to listen to them, tell it to the church.
And if he refuses to listen even to the church, let him be
to you as a gentile and a tax collector.
So do you see what was happening?
A person that you believe is a Christian brother
or sister, sins against you.
And so you go to them and you confront them over it
and you tell them, here's what happened.
It's not a preference issue.
It's not like, I didn't like your shirt the other day.
Right? You're not doing any of that stuff.
It's a clear, in God's word, genuine sin.
Here's what you did. Here's what it did to me.
I'm confronting. And what was their response?
Well, ideally they would listen,
they would respond, they would repent.
And then you've won. You've restored the relationship.
That's the ideal. But Jesus says,
that's not always what happens.
We don't know exactly how this person responded negatively,
but, but maybe it was something like that person comes
to them and says, Hey brother, listen, this was a sin.
It hurt me. Here's what you did.
Nah, man, that's, that's not a sin.
I don't, I don't think you're interpreting that right, man.
Man, you're just being legalistic.
Stop, you're, you're pushing it too far, man.
No, listen, that's not that big a deal.
Why are you making it a big deal? It doesn't hurt that bad.
Like why? We don't know what they said.
But that's the picture we get here.
And what does all that sound like?
It's pride. It's pride that no, no, I'm not wrong.
Well, what happens next? Well, that person
who brought the sin forward, the confronter
because they love the person.
They bring one or two with them to just make sure
that they're hearing everything right.
Like, man, maybe I missed it.
Maybe, maybe I'm misunderstanding something here.
And can we get some objective observers here and and listen
and, and talk it out and think it through.
And maybe we're both wrong maybe, but let's figure it out.
Here's what I believe happened.
Here's the sin that I believe happened yet again.
What was the response in Matthew 18?
Ideally the response is that
that person, oh yep, I was wrong.
I'm sorry, repent restored.
But that isn't what happened here.
Again, a prideful
Refusal.
Third step involves the church.
But notice if they even refuse that.
What did verse 17 say about that person
who then even refuses that
Jesus said treat them as a gentile and a tax collector.
Those were catchall terms for people who are
outside the church,
essentially unbelievers you
Might say.
And so I wanna be clear what Jesus just said.
He's not saying that we know for sure
that person is an unbeliever
because ultimately we don't know.
Like I don't know any of you sitting right here.
Like I'm just assuming I'm kind of reading the fruit.
I'm like, okay, yeah, I probably
but, but like we don't know.
It's between you and God.
We have plenty of occasions
where people have been acting like believers saying they're
believers and on the last day they end up not believers.
Like that's the reality of it.
And so I don't know if somebody refuses to repent, repent,
repent, all those things like I don't know, that's
between them and God.
But they certainly are acting like one
again.
Why? Because of their pride.
Refusing to see, listen again.
If you refuse to see
that your sin is separating you from God,
if you refuse to see that your sin is hurting those
around you, that's just arrogance.
And it gives evidence that as far as we can tell, again,
we don't know for sure, we hope we're wrong.
But as far as we can tell,
the Holy Spirit is not active in your life
because Jesus promised the Holy Spirit was
gonna convict of sin.
And refusing that seeming to refuse that over
and over means like, well, we is the Holy Spirit there.
Which means they're not a believer.
That's why we must reject pride,
because eternity may be in the balance.
It may be revealing something about your soul that is not
eternally good.
'cause remember why Satan was thrown outta heaven.
Isaiah 14 says that Satan fell from heaven
because of his pride.
He wanted to be God. He wanted to sit on the throne.
He's like, why does he get to and none of us do?
He wanted and he was cast out of heaven because of pride.
Listen, I don't want you, I don't want anyone
to get to that last day where you're standing before Jesus
and in that moment you get exposed as a fraud.
But Jesus, didn't we do all these things in your name?
Didn't we do all these great things? He's like away from me.
I never knew you because
you never humbled yourself
Before me.
Listen, if you don't humble yourself before the
Lord, Which is revealed as you humble yourself
before other people, like if you don't humble yourself
before the Lord beware eternity, that poison
of pride will destroy your soul.
So there's an eternal part of this that we cannot deny.
We can't move past, like there's something here
eternally we have to be aware of.
But I also, not only eternally, I don't want you
to suffer the consequences of a life lived in prideful,
selfish focus, that it brings carnage in your life.
Like if you just live about me, it's about me.
It's about me. Everyone is damaged around
You.
I
Want you to flourish.
I want those around you to flourish.
I want those around you to feel blessed and loved
because your, your posture is towards them
and it's sacrificial towards like that humble stance
brings life to those around you.
Pride only takes and takes and takes.
Okay, so how do we get there?
We've identified the problem.
Well, thankfully, verse 16 doesn't just stop in verse
six with that first phrase.
It also shares the antidote
To The poison of pride.
It moves from negative to positive.
It says, do not be haughty but associate with the lowly.
That's a contrasting statement.
That word in the middle is a compare contrast word.
Don't be prideful. Instead associate with the lowly.
Okay? That word associate means be led by or
or carried away with.
It's similar to what we talked about a couple weeks ago
with, with hospitality that you don't just tolerate people,
you affectionately build relationships with them.
You care, you circle up, you become friends, right?
That's what we're talking about here, associating
with the lowly.
Well, next question, who are the lowly?
Well, that word in the New Testament is used about people
who are two things.
One in a position socially that's low.
But it's also used about people who are humble.
Like you know those people in
your life, those who are humble.
That's what it's saying. They are lowly.
So don't think it's a negative term.
It's, it's an unfortunate word in English, but,
but it, it doesn't mean anything about value.
It's often set in contrast to proud or rich or mighty.
And so you take the opposite of that,
what we're talking about, humility.
Lowly is poor, weak, humble.
They're the uneducated, the social outcasts.
The ones with no connections, no influence.
The widow, the orphan, the stranger,
the one Jesus said in Matthew 25, the least of these,
Again, not talking about value in any way
because what verse 16 doesn't say is show pity
to those people or help those people like you have a lot.
So give them money. Like that's not what it says at all.
It says instead we are to associate with them.
We are to come alongside them.
We are to become their companions, their friends.
We are to be with them like seeing them, sources of joy,
sources of wisdom, learn from them.
They have much to offer us. That's what it's talking about.
In fact, the people in this category
often have spiritual riches that those who are proud
and wealthy
lack, just think about it.
They know their need. They have no delusions
of self-sufficiency.
They understand grace in a way that those
who are maybe successful in the eyes
of the world don't understand.
And so we have a lot to learn when we
associate with people like that.
We are enriched as we do that.
We learn desperate dependence.
Our church talks about that all the time.
We learn it whenever we're with people
who are in that place.
So here's the point. We in contrast to being prideful
and the poison that is must treasure the unassuming company
of the humble, like we need to treasure
the unassuming company of the humble,
like those who are quiet, those who are weak, those
who are poor, treasure time with them,
Don't just tolerate treasure.
This is again where the standard of Jesus described
by Romans 12 is so radically counter-cultural.
'cause this is Jesus' standard here, associate with the low.
This is where it completely flies against
what we live every day.
'cause what it does is it exposes
that we often measure from the bottom up in our lives,
like we're, we're measuring by the world's standard.
Like we're, we're way off.
'cause here's what the world says to do.
Everything around us teaches us to climb the social ladder,
to network with the influential,
to schmooze those who can like advance our career
or boost our status, right?
And get a right group. So I
gotta stand in this group over here.
Oh look, I'm talking to these
people, but those people came in.
I gotta go over there, right?
Like that's what the world says. But hear me.
Who you seek out reveals what you value.
Pride gravitates towards status.
Humility seeks out need.
Who needs me right now? Who needs something right now?
Not who can provide something for me right now?
Who needs something I can fulfill right now?
And isn't, isn't this what Jesus modeled for us?
Like isn't this how Jesus lived his life?
If, if we're looking at the standard, this is
how Jesus did it, right?
Matthew 1930, Jesus said, many who are first will be last.
And the last, first Matthew
2028, the son of man, Jesus came not to be served
but to serve
Philippians two, talking about his incarnation.
Verse seven says, he emptied himself, he set aside the glory
that he had and took the form of a servant,
born among the animals surrounded by shepherds,
raised in the backwater town of Nazareth,
eventually hanging out with fishermen
and tax collectors, not just speaking a word to a leper
to heal them, but actually touching a leper to heal them.
Listen, if we're gonna be like Jesus, we have to go
where Jesus went to go
where he is.
Not in a fake way, not in a patronizing way.
In an associating way.
The scripture says like real valuing,
recognizing other people saying, come on in, come on in.
Because here's the, here's the truth.
There are no unimportant members in the body of Christ.
There's not a high and low in the kingdom of God.
I'm not more important to the kingdom of God than you are.
She's not more important than he is like
that's not at at all.
We are all, there's one king on the throne
and the rest of us are just beggars Who found bread?
And here's this, this, this, this got me this week
when we associate with the, the category, again,
not value, but the category of those who are humble,
the lowly, when we associate with them, it's just really
where all of us should be anyway.
If there's a king and it's not me, it's not you,
It Then we are all down here.
We're all lowly. So let's stop acting like we're not.
And let's be lowly together, humble before the king.
But again, man,
That's Not the way the world thinks, is it?
You don't associate with a lowly.
They can't give anything to you.
They can't do anything for you. So you don't do this.
And here's the truth. You
and I have marinated in that selfish, prideful,
wealthy culture most if not all of our lives.
And so it is really difficult for us
to think differently than that for us not
to just get caught up in this status game
and not think like Jesus.
It's easy for us to get there. It's hard to admit weakness.
So we need Christ to reshape our minds,
to redo our thoughts.
Remember all the way back in verse two,
do not be conformed to this world.
Be transformed by the renewal of your mind
by different thinking.
Similar here in verse 16, right?
Never be wise in your own sight. It's pride.
It's not saying abandon all thinking.
Stop learning. That's not what this is saying.
God gave us minds to foster, to build, to grow.
That's what we should be doing with our minds.
What this is is a warning
to abandon the deadly delusion of self wisdom.
That this delusion that we are wise in ourselves is deadly
and we should abandon it.
We cannot think that our wisdom is sufficient.
We cannot think that our understanding needs no correction.
We cannot think that, that we, we,
we can't think that I don't need input,
that I don't need help,
that my perspective is the final word.
That's all delusions of self wisdom.
That that we have some prideful version of
who we think we are and
what we can think about being wise in my own sight
says I'm the final authority.
I don't need anybody else. I certainly don't need
God's word to correct me.
I can figure this out myself.
Listen, that's not merely foolish.
That is rebellion against God. Almighty
Proverbs speaks to this.
Proverbs one, seven says, the fear of the Lord
is the beginning of knowledge only.
Fools despise wisdom and instruction.
Pride makes you fear being wrong,
fear being shown up, fear being corrected.
And you only end up being unreachable,
unteachable and unbearable.
Humility on the other hand, humility makes you
fear being on your own.
It makes you fear a lack of counsel.
It makes you fear being outside of God's word
and you end up being more fruitful and wiser
and your life flourishes.
Don't hear me say that. You're losing your ability to think.
You're gaining the ability to think God's thoughts
after him, which is the definition of wisdom.
How would God think about my life and my day?
I wanna think those thoughts. How's he doing that?
That's wisdom. You're gaining the ability to do that
as you listen to him and his people and his word.
'cause here's the reality. Sin has
corrupted every facet of our lives.
It Touches everything.
And so we need the word of God to correct us.
We need the spirit of God to guide us.
We need the people of God to counsel us.
And ultimately we need the, the God of the universe
to completely reshape our hearts.
We need him to change everything about our lives.
'cause that's the only true antidote to the poison of pride.
It's the gospel of Jesus Christ.
It's so deep rooted in there.
It's so saturated in the world around us.
There is nothing we can do to remove it ourselves.
Only God has to remove it. And here's how he does that.
Like when we stop for a second
and consider what God has done for us
and we just stop and think about how, how we brought nothing
to the table except the sin that made salvation necessary,
that should just blow our minds
and humble us from the very beginning.
Like if we honestly assess our lives and we look around
and we think about how far from God we are, how prideful,
how selfish, all of these things, how much we actually are,
and then we reflect on the grace
and mercy of God toward us, even as his enemies,
that he would say, you're my enemy.
I'm gonna bring you into my family by my son's life.
I'm gonna bring you in. Like if we think about that,
that should make us the most humble
people on the face of the earth, right?
Nothing we deserve. There's no way we could earn it.
We just had all against God.
And he said, no, no, come on, you're mine.
Why would we walk around preening and pretentious?
Why would we think we have anything
awesome to bring to the table?
It is all God.
And so we should be humble like God, just think about this.
God saved you. God saved
me like his enemy.
God looked at me and said, I'm saving you,
paying for it with my son.
Like how could I not fall in my face in
Response to that?
So again, these, these commands here in Romans 12
reject pride, embrace the lowly abandon self wisdom.
They, they are not burdens to bear.
These Are gifts to receive
Because These will lead us out of the prison of pride
and self-sufficiency.
And they will lead us into the joyful freedom of humility
and fellowship with God and with others.
Because Here's what James four, six
Says, God opposes the
Proud, But gives grace to the humble.
I don't want God opposed to
Me.
I wanna take a simple parable of Jesus
to close our time today.
This is a story you've probably heard before.
It's actually so outrageous it, it kind of makes me chuckle.
It's actually kind of funny the the way Jesus says it.
But here's what I hope we hear it
and read it with a little differently today with,
with open eyes and hearts.
Now in light of what God has shown us in his word,
how we hear this,
and as I read it, I would invite you just to ask God
to reveal where you see yourself
and then maybe where you should see yourself.
This is Luke 18, nine through 14.
Jesus also told this parable to some
who trusted in themselves that they were righteous
and treated others with contempt.
Two men went up into the temple to pray.
One a Pharisee and the other attacks collector.
The Pharisee standing by himself prayed.
Thus, God, I thank you that I am not like other men,
extortioners, unjust, adulterers
or even like this tax collector.
I fast twice a week. I give ties of all that I give.
But the tax collector standing far off
would not even lift up his eyes to heaven.
But he beat his chest saying, God, be merciful
to me a sinner.
I tell you, this man went down to his house justified
rather than the other.
For everyone who exalts himself will be humbled,
but the one who exalts,
humbles himself will be exalted.
Lord, we come to you through your word
and asking you humbly
to reveal to us where our pride
permeates every part of our lives.
So God, I pray you would reveal that poison
where it is, how deeply it is embedded in our lives.
And Lord, you'd rip it out, replant
humility in our hearts that we, we'd be willing to share,
willing to open our lives, willing to,
to not put on a facade
and a fake image of, of who we really are.
God, that we just be real who we are
because we already in Christ are accepted before you.
We don't have to be accepted by anybody else,
but Lord, that humility, God,
we know you've promised that that would change
everything in our lives.
But God, it's hard to admit weakness.
It's hard to be in that place.
It's hard for me to not love myself more than I should.
So we come to you together, Lord,
and I pray for every one of us that we would all
recognize the need for humility
and we would all walk towards you more humbly,
crucifying ourselves, crucifying the pride
to see others is more significant, to serve others
to confess and repent of sin where we need to,
even the small things that it wouldn't just be
about us all the time.
That the world would see something different.
Or maybe church, maybe you, today's you're here
and you recognize you've never
humbled yourself before the Lord.
You've played the church game,
but you've never humbled yourself before God.
And today you see your need for that,
and you see that He listen.
I hope you see it, that he's offered you forgiveness for
that pride, forgiveness for that rebellion against him.
He's offering it and you just have to receive it.
You just have to look at him and say, God, I'm yours.
Pray you do that today. Just walk into
that freedom outta the prison of pride,
self-importance.
Just realize that it's only about his
importance, it's about him.
So that's what we're gonna sing.
Christ, be magnified, pray that you would
And that we live that way.
So if you're able to stand together, let's magnify the one
who is worthy of it.